according to a new survey 70% of
American Millennials say they'll likely
vote socialist and one in three of them
view communism favorably this as
positive opinions about capitalism has
dropped given that the top sight read by
Millennials is BuzzFeed no wonder they
think Pol Pot is inedible but we've been
down this road before where we mock
Millennials for their ignorance over
systems that have killed as many people
as cholera but maybe it's on us
somewhere along the line we broke our
commitments to transfer the truths of
history to incoming earthlings
you can't blame young people for getting
sport for getting stuff you never taught
him and although socialism is a sweet
idea
there's no college course called intro
to sweet ideas that kill millions two
analogies we used to know that vaccines
save millions of lives
but once measles is nearly wiped out
what happens we forget and start talking
about vaccines as an option like a
sunroof then measles return the horrible
effects of socialism and communism seem
remote like a hangover you had from
tequila back when you were 16 you threw
up for two days and swore never again
but in a year you do humans can forget
the things that nearly killed them in
the same survey 72 percent of all
Americans wrongly believe communism
killed under a hundred million people in
the last 100 years it's more over a
hundred million people killed by
something that many people today see is
nice given how modern media and academia
deem humans as disposable hazards on an
overcrowded planet that will certainly
end in ten years maybe that's why they
romanticize this awful stuff thin the
herd as they say
Jesse you're a fan among Millennials I
am what would you tell them I would tell
them that the socialism in Scandinavia
that success story is a complete and
utter myth the scale Canadian countries
are ranked some of the top capitalist
free market economies in the entire
world
they have a very generous welfare system
because they have an amazing capitalist
system with low taxes and low regulation
the Scandinavian countries we're going
on a socialist route until about 40
years ago when the economy started
tanking they kicked all the politicians
out and they slashed the estate tax
corporate taxes income taxes they have
school choice there they don't have a
lot of regulations unions are not very
tough there is no minimum wage laws in
these countries so they can afford this
great health care system there it takes
care of everybody because they don't get
involved and over regulate and overly
tax these companies and these
individuals income now have you ever
heard a groundbreaking result from
research and study in the healthcare
industry in the Scandinavian countries
no all the groundbreaking medical
research happens in America because we
have the freedom we have today well I
would say to this you have young people
in this country who feel that the
system's been rigged up against him and
I would just advise everyone listening
hate Trump benefit a lot from this in
terms of older people thinking hey this
system is rigged against me but young
people say hey you know why am i paying
all these high bills for school why is
the health care system so bad why are so
many schools you got to largely not good
schools and so why is that so they don't
see Venezuela they don't see all the GOP
fear-mongering what they see is Denmark
Scandinavia and they say hey these
people have good health care these
people have good schools less income
inequality and more opportunity either
way opportunity there small country by
the way when it comes to a Happiness
index all through the world the happiest
countries are these countries the South
Bay because why does everybody want to
move to America why
Kennedy's explodes into a giant pumpkin
I would I would challenge that assertion
that these are the happiest countries in
the world the the fact that Americans
may be less happy is their economic
mobility has essentially been slashed
and shackled the President and
Republicans are half right yes you have
to cut taxes people have to be able to
take more of their money home and that's
what improves consumer confidence and
allows people to spend more money and
hire more workers for their small
businesses and that's an incredible
thing and I think socialism actually has
a better PR person and people who
embrace capitalism have to marry it to
creativity because that's the best thing
about America if you have good ideas
you are not strangled by a cultural
caste system and by the way some of the
countries that you idealize they're
actually very homogenous yes very very
it's also true that the big companies
like the googles and the Amazons in this
country are strangling up making it
harder because of crony capitalism we
need more freedom and by the way my mom
came over on a boat from Romania her her
parents took three kids and one suitcase
because they had to outrun the commies
and and their country was decimated by
socialism and communism and those are
real stories and those are people whose
private property was taken away by force
and they had to craft all new dreams and
they did that here my grandparents sent
all four of their kids to college three
of whom served in the Navy that's the
American dream but I let me think their
talk the young people are talking about
state ownership of major industry many
of the younger people on this spectrum
have grown up in a period of you know 10
plus years of economic expansion through
no fault of their own they don't
actually understand what it's like to be
in an economy that's what they didn't go
up during the Cold War they don't
understand what happened in October
under President Kennedy they have a lack
of knowledge I think to your point you
know we need to require more of these
civics lessons that also sort of clue
people in on you know the pluses and
minus
of some of these economic systems I mean
I would recommend that you know people
love to do a semester abroad exchange
programs let's send kids to places like
Venezuela Cuba learn or Cuba where they
really can see firsthand what it is like
to experience those places it might also
be a good idea to have those exchange
work the other way so that some of the
children in those countries could
experience what capitalism offers
because I think they're you know I mean
I love these kids I'm some of them are
my own but they're living and you need
to experience the other side to
understand what wouldn't even like raise
a communist did you mark oh my gosh one
is raising Republicans you're going to
raise liberals